for one final time putting your alien
slash god hat on and you look at human
civilization
the do you think uh about the 7.8
billion people on earth
as individual little creatures
individual organisms
or do you think of us as uh
one organism with the collective
intelligence
what's the proper framework through
which to analyze it
again as an alien so that i know where
you're coming from would you have asked
the question the same way
before the industrial revolution before
the agricultural revolution when there
were half a billion people and no
telecommunications connecting them
i would indeed ask the question the same
way but i would be less confident about
about your conclusions um
it would be an actually more interesting
way to ask the question at that time but
i was nevertheless asked it the same way
yes well let's go back further and
smaller then
rather than just a single human or the
entire human species let's look at
a relatively isolated tribe yes in the
relatively isolated probably sub dunbar
number sub kin 150 people
tribe do i look at that as one
entity where evolution is selecting for
based on group selection or do i think
of it as 150 individuals
um that are interacting in some way
well could those individuals exist
without the group
no the
evolutionary adaptiveness of humans
was involved critically group selection
and
individual humans alone trying to figure
out stone tools and protection and
whatever
uh aren't what was selected for
and so i think the or is the wrong
frame i think it's
individuals are affecting the group that
they're a part of
they're also dependent upon and being
affected by the group that they're part
of
and so this now starts to get in deep
into political theories
also which is theories that orient
towards the collective at different
scales whether a tribal scale or an
empire or nation state or something and
ones that orient towards the individual
liberalism and stuff like that
and i think there's very obvious failure
modes on both sides
and so the relationship between them is
more interesting to me than either of
them the relationship between the
individual and the collective and the
question around how to have a virtuous
process between those so
a good social system would be one where
the organism of the individual and the
organism
of the group of individuals is they're
both synergistic to each other so what
is best for the individuals and what's
best for the whole is aligned
but there is nevertheless an individual
they're not it's uh it's a matter of
degrees i suppose but
what is uh what defines a human
more the the social
network within the which they've been
brought up
through which they've developed their
intelligence or is it their
own sovereign individual self
like what's your intuition of how much
not just for
evolutionary survival but as
intellectual beings how much do we need
others
for our development yeah i think we have
a weird sense of this today
relative to most previous periods of
sapient history
i think the vast majority of sapient
history is tribal
like depending upon your early
human model two or three hundred
thousand years of
homo sapiens and little tribes where
they depended upon that tribe for
survival and excommunication from the
tribe was
was fatal i think they and our whole
evolutionary genetic history is in that
environment and the amount of time we've
been out of it is
is relatively so tiny and then
we still depended upon extended families
and local communities more
and the big kind of giant market complex
where
i can provide something to the market to
get money to be able to get other things
from the market where it seems like i
don't need anyone it's almost like
disintermediating our sense of need even
though
even though your my ability to talk to
each other
using these mics and the phones that we
coordinated on took millions of people
over six continents to be able to run
the supply chains it made all the stuff
that we depend on but we don't notice
that we depend upon them they all seem
fungible
um if you take a baby obviously that you
didn't even get to a baby without a mom
was it dependent or you depend upon each
other right without
two two parents at minimum and they
depended upon other people
but if we take that baby and we put it
out in the wild it obviously dies
so if we let it grow up for a little
while the minimum amount of time where
it starts to have some autonomy and then
we put it out in the wild and
this has happened a few times it doesn't
learn language
and it doesn't learn the artic
the small motor articulation that we
learn it doesn't
learn the type of consciousness that we
end up having that is socialized
so i think i think we take for granted
how much conditioning affects us um
is it possible that uh
it affects basically 99.9
or maybe the whole thing the whole thing
is the connection between us humans
and that were we're uh no better than
apes
without our human connections because
that
that thinking of it that way
forces us to think very differently
about human society and how to progress
forward
if the connections are fundamental i
just
have to object to the no better than
apes because better here i think you
mean a specific thing which means have
capacities that are fundamentally
different than i think apes also depend
upon
troops um yes and
i i think the idea of humans as better
than
nature in some kind of ethical sense
ends up having heaps of problems we'll
table that we can come back to it but
when we say what is unique about homo
sapien capacity relative to the other
animals we currently
inhabit the biosphere with and i'm
saying it that way because there were
other early hominids that had some of
these capacities
we believe our tool creation and our
language creation and our coordination
are all kind of the results of
a certain type of capacity for
abstraction
and other animals will use tools but
they don't evolve the tools they use
they keep using the same types of tools
that they
basically can find so a chimp will
notice
that a rock can cut a vine that it wants
to and it'll even notice that a sharper
rock will cut it better and
experientially it'll use the sharper
rock and if you even give it a knife
it'll probably use the knife because
it's experiencing the effectiveness
but it doesn't make stone tools because
that requires understanding
why one is sharper than the other what
is the abstract principle called
sharpness
to then be able to invent a sharper
thing that same abstraction makes
language
and the ability for abstract
representation which
makes the ability to coordinate in a
more
advanced set of ways so i do think our
ability to coordinate with each other is
pretty fundamental to the selection of
what we are
as a species i wonder if that
coordination that connection
is actually the thing that gives birth
to consciousness that gives birth to
well let's start with self awareness
more like theory of mind
theory of mind yeah you know i i i
suppose there's experiments that show
that there's other mammals that
have a very crude theory of mind i'm not
sure maybe dogs
something like that but actually dogs
probably has to do with that they
co-evolved with humans
you